this is our second time at the con with
Archer we're going into our third season
and it was you know I think our show is
specifically well suited to the comp
because it's an animated show it's a
beautifully animated show it's also
really very kind of accommodation of
very very smart very erudite very
raunchy so we have a really specific
relationship with our fans I'm in doing
comedy for 18 years so I have a very
well established relationship with my
fan base and I think because I've done a
lot of comedy a lot of comedic shows
that are very much an embodiment my
sensibility I did talk soup which is
pretty much a male-dominated fanbase
that shows like 6040 men and women i
have i have groups of men that come to
my shows without girls i have faster
parties to come to my show so I've a
very nice my act is very male friendly
and my sense of humor is I'm just I was
raised by single down very much a guy's
girl so my shows I have guy fans and
they don't come because they brought
their girlfriend they come because they
want to see me and I've a lot of guys
who say you're my favorite comedian not
you're my favorite girl comedian or I
think you're funny forchick but you're
my favorite comics so that's not
something i cultivated I'm just who I am
on stage I just happen to be a great guy
friendly comic this that's my sense of
humor so I'm received just fine you know
what I mean I think in the end you have
to do comedy that's a peer expression
who you are and not try to not try to
win people over based on what you think
they're gonna like you just have to do
what you think it's funny but for me I
grew up with a single dad I played video
games all of us growing up I'm actually
I was raised on action movies I was
raised on the back of a motorcycle so I
just talk about this stuff i like it
just happens to me things that guys like
to and in fact the name of my podcast is
girl on guy with Aisha Tyler a podcast
about stuff guys love so it's really a
show that's about the stuff that I'm
already into and talking about that
stuff with guys I'm a huge gamer i did a
voice in the last halo game and so this
is just already in my world so I'm
growing guys isn't as an audio in the
podcast it launches june july july
twenty six so
Tuesday July 26 and and we have some
amazing guests including a lot of guys
from Archer and Maggie Q and shane west
from Nikita and the Sklar brothers and
brett erlich from infomania and Jackie
Kashian is an amazing comedian and it's
mostly guys we will have women on the
show and those those shows will be
called a special girl on girl additional
girl on guy but it's really about its
really talking to you about stuff that
they love their typically kind of guy
centric things because there are a lot
of women you know I am a gamer and it's
not an idea i had Ivan I mean I was
raised on defender and galaga and so
when I talk about gaming it's a passion
that I have it's not like I'm like let's
talk about it as you know this is my
world already so but the show is about
things that are traditionally kind of
guy guy oriented stuff but it really
doesn't matter who's on the show it's
just about what they're into so I'm when
I had Jackie Kashian on the show we just
she's really into Tolkien and fantasy
and dnd and World of Warcraft and that's
the stuff we talked about when she was
on but but it's a no-holds-barred show
there's no language restrictions on
topic restrictions and what I love about
is it gives people a chance to come on
the show and have a conversation they
wouldn't get to have if they were going
on this tonight show or a lot of these
people are you know really well
established and what they do but they
get to just be themselves speak the way
they would normally speak with their
friends we're going to be talking to a
bunch of pro skaters NASCAR drivers
bucky lasek who is competing at the x
games next week i went to e3 and i got
to talk to the halo halo anniversary
halo 4 reboot guys i did a podcast with
Cliff Bleszinski who's the design
director at epic and you know obviously
created the Gears of War franchise so
it's really a show for guys and think of
people that are into guy stuff